Se pourrait-il qu'être trop intelligent nous rende bêtes ?
C'est en tout cas l'idée que je vais essayer de défendre dans cette vidéo.
Préparez-vous, générique !
D'abord, il faut qu'on s'entende sur ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence.
L'intelligence, ce n'est pas la culture.
Si vous préférez, ce n'est pas parce qu'on a lu des livres ou qu'on à bac +5 qu'on est intelligent.
Savoir qui était le dieu de
la guerre chez les Romains,
savoir combien il y a d'os dans le corps humain, c'est de la culture.
Cela montre qu'on a étudié et qu'on a une bonne capacité de mémorisation.
Mais, sur le plan intellectuel,
ce n'est pas différent de connaître la liste des Pokémons.
Cela peut aider au Trivial Pursuit, mais cela ne fait pas de nous quelqu'un d'intelligent.
L'intelligence, ce n'est pas la mémoire,
à moins de penser qu'un disque dur soit intelligent.
Alors l'intelligence, c'est quoi ?
Au sens premier,
l'intelligence, c'est la capacité à comprendre les choses par le recours au raisonnement,
c'est l'aptitude à mettre en oeuvre une réflexion pour résoudre un problème ou pour expliquer une situation.
Ce qui signifie déjà qu'il ne faut pas confondre
"intelligent" et "intellectuel".
Un bûcheron qui scie le tronc d'un arbre de sorte que l'arbre tombe dans une certaine direction,
un boxeur qui analyse les déplacements de son adversaire pour le coincer dans les cordes,
c'est de l'intelligence.
Ce qui serait stupide, ce serait de courir après son adversaire pour lui porter des coups sans réfléchir,
ou de scier l'arbre sans se poser la question de savoir où il va atterrir.
L'intelligence, c'est donc une capacité de projection et
d'anticipation,
qui passe par l'analyse des paramètres en présence.
C'est l'aptitude à établir des connexions entre les causes et les effets,
qui va nous permettre de prévoir ce qui va arriver en
fonction de ce qui est arrivé ou de ce que je m'apprête à faire.
Si je vends mon lit le matin et que le soir
je me demande où je vais dormir,
c'est que manifestement je n'ai pas fait preuve d'intelligence,
puisque je n'ai pas
anticipé la conséquence directe de mon acte.
Je n'ai pas
établi la relation logique entre l'événement A et l'événement B.
Cela nous conduit à une deuxième définition de l'intelligence qui est :
le sens de l'adaptation.
On peut reprendre l'exemple du bûcheron que j'utilisais tout à l'heure :
si le bûcheron sait dans quelle direction va tomber l'arbre, il va pouvoir
adapter son comportement à cette information, par exemple en évitant de rester planté juste en-dessous.
Bon, après, chacun fait comme il veut...
Comme pour le sens de l'anticipation, le sens de l'adaptation peut prendre différentes formes selon les contextes.
Par exemple, si j'ai un ami dont les parents viennent de mourir...
Oui, j'ai décidé de mettre l'ambiance...
et que je lui raconte que mes parents sont en train de passer leur deuxième lune de miel aux
Bahamas, à ce moment-là, ce que je dis n'est pas intelligent au sens où c'est inapproprié à la
situation.
Je n'anticipe pas les conséquences de mes paroles sur celui qui est en face de moi,
je ne prends pas en compte sa situation émotionnelle.
L'intelligence est un phénomène protéiforme,
et l'erreur serait de réduire l'intelligence à sa version logique et mathématique.
Le QI (quotient intellectuel) est un outil qui permet de mesurer l'intelligence logique.
Et dans la culture occidentale,
c'est généralement le QI qui sert de référence à la mesure de l'intelligence.
Mais on peut avoir 150 de QI être un parfait abruti sur
le plan émotionnel,
relationnel ou manuel.
Il y a des gens qui sont capables de calculer mentalement la racine cubique d'un nombre à six chiffres,
mais qui sont de véritables
estropiés sur le plan émotionnel
ou qui ne sauraient pas se servir d'un tournevis.
Si je rencontre quelqu'un pour la première fois et que je lui dis que sa tronche ne me revient pas,
je lui dis peut-être ce que je pense, mais sur le plan relationnel je me tire une balle dans le pied puisque je lui envoie
un message
d'hostilité alors qu'il ne m'a rien fait.
Et ça, de toute évidence, ce n'est pas être intelligent.
Je vous ai fait une petite sélection
de livres sur la question de l'intelligence que vous trouverez en description de cette vidéo.
J'ai choisi des livres relativement
accessibles pour que chacun puisse piocher dans ce qui l'intéresse,
que ce soit sur la question du QI ou sur celle des intelligences multiples, qui est un concept que je vous invite à découvrir si
vous ne le connaissez pas.
Donc on a bien compris que l'intelligence était d'abord une capacité de projection et d'adaptation à un contexte.
Mais cela ne répond pas directement à la question initiale qui était de savoir :
en quoi être trop intelligent peut-il rendre bête ?
Parce qu'a priori, l'excès d'intelligence n'a jamais été un problème.
On n'a jamais entendu quelqu'un nous dire : "Oh là là, attention ! Tu es trop intelligent, il faudrait que tu lèves le pied !"
Eh bien vous allez voir
que ce n'est pas aussi simple que cela en a l'air.
L'excès d'intelligence, c'est quand l'intelligence n'est plus investie dans la résolution de problèmes
existants,
mais dans la création de problèmes artificiels.
L'excès d'intelligence, c'est lorsque nous analysons les choses, non pas parce que la situation l'exige,
mais parce que nous avons un besoin irrépressible de tout analyser.
C'est lorsque, par notre pensée, nous
complexifions inutilement les choses,
juste pour le plaisir d'avoir des problèmes à résoudre.
À ce moment-là, l'intelligence n'est donc plus un moyen de résoudre des problèmes, mais un
moyen de les entretenir, voire de les amplifier,
juste pour satisfaire notre besoin de réfléchir.
Et réfléchir sur un problème qui n'existe pas, ce n'est pas de l'intelligence.
C'est le contraire de l'intelligence, puisque l'intelligence sert à résoudre !
Donc quand je parle d'un excès d'intelligence, je parle en fait d'une
hypertrophie de l'intellect, je parle d'un excès de l'activité mentale,
qui se fait au détriment de la compréhension.
À partir du moment où réfléchir n'est plus un moyen de comprendre mais devient une
finalité en soi,
à partir du moment où analyser n'est plus quelque chose d'utile mais un besoin incontrôlable,
on sort de l'intelligence,
on devient une machine à penser.
Il y a des personnes très intelligentes qui sont capables d'élaborer des scénarios
intellectuels extrêmement sophistiqués.
L'ennui, c'est que ces scénarios ne correspondent à aucune nécessité
pratique.
Ce sont des labyrinthes sans issue qui ne débouchent sur aucune solution.
Et le problème, c'est que pendant qu'on s'épuise à fabriquer des
scénarios mentaux, on ne vit plus.
L'hypertrophie de l'intellect nous rend complètement aveugle aux évidences.
Un peu comme si l'évidence était quelque chose de trop simple pour
satisfaire notre esprit.
On ne voit pas des choses qui sautent aux yeux de n'importe qui,
tout simplement parce qu'on tient à avoir des problèmes à résoudre, et que ne plus avoir de problèmes, ce serait comme cesser d'exister.
On ne cherche pas à résoudre : on cherche à avoir quelque chose à résoudre
justement pour ne pas le résoudre !
C'est ce que j'appelle l'intelligence
masochiste :
c'est l'intelligence qui se bat contre elle-même.
Parce que, encore une fois, créer de toutes pièces un problème qui n'existe pas,
ou extrapoler un problème qui pourrait être résolu de manière simple, ce n'est pas être intelligent.
C'est juste travailler à se faire souffrir et à se rendre malheureux.
Il y a un auteur qui s'appelle Eckhart Tolle, qui parle, lui, de la "pensée compulsive".
Là encore, vous trouverez tous les liens dans la description.
La pensée compulsive, c'est quand on ne parvient pas à
interrompre la pensée.
C'est quand on a besoin de se poser des questions
et qu'on tourne en boucle dans nos schémas mentaux
sans jamais parvenir à se reposer.
La pensée compulsive, c'est un phénomène
involontaire, dont on n'est pas forcément conscient, mais dont on peut prendre conscience
à partir du moment où on devient le témoin
intérieur de nos pensées.
Et Eckhart Tolle explique que dans cette course effrénée du mental,
dans ce travail de remue-méninges permanent qui fait qu'on va toujours être
insatisfait, on s'épuise et on se perd.
* Le penseur compulsif c'est-à-dire presque tout le monde, vit dans un état *
* d'apparente division, dans un monde *
* déraisonnablement complexe où foisonnent perpétuellement problèmes *
* et conflits. *
* Un monde qui reflète l'incessante *
* fragmentation du mental. *
* Le philosophe français Descartes a cru avoir découvert la vérité la plus fondamentale *
* quand il fit sa célèbre déclaration : *
* "Je pense, donc je suis". Il venait en fait de formuler l'erreur la plus fondamentale, *
* celle d'assimiler la pensée à l'être, et l'identité à la pensée. *
La pensée compulsive, c'est ce besoin que nous avons de nous infliger une torture mentale
alors que personne ne nous le demande.
C'est Schopenhauer qui disait que l'homme était le seul animal capable d'être malheureux,
parce que c'est le seul animal qui possède un intellect.
Autrement dit, c'est le seul animal qui se pose des questions.
On souffre parce qu'on a des questions sans réponse.
Et pour conjurer cette souffrance,
pour la faire disparaître,
il n'y a que deux possibilités :
soit on trouve la réponse à nos questions,
soit on arrête de se poser des questions.
L'intelligence nous rend bêtes à partir du moment où elle sert uniquement à nous rendre malheureux.
Et je répète souvent cette phrase qu'on trouve aussi
chez Eckhart Tolle :
bien souvent, le chemin est simple,
c'est nous qui sommes compliqués.
La pensée est un outil formidable à partir du moment où on la contrôle.
Elle devient notre ennemi à partir du moment où c'est elle qui nous contrôle.
Merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode,
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de partager la vidéo sur vos réseaux sociaux.
Rejoignez-moi sur Facebook, "Le Précepteur",
je suis également présent sur Instagram.
Et, comme à chaque fois, un grand merci aux tipeurs pour leur soutien indéfectible.
Je vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain épisode.